hello everyone and welcome to another
game from round three of the Prague
chess festival the masters division we
said that we're gonna check out at least
one more game since there were a lot of
the size of games before we check out
the standings
it's a Santos Gujarati visit a versus
Austrian grandmaster Marcos rigueur who
won the Austrian championship three
times and is the first Austrian player
to ever cross the 2700 threshold I don't
know if there are any others so I'm
pretty sure he's not only the first one
he's the only one but still definitely a
strong player so without further ado
let's check it out now it's gonna be so
it's a pretty long theoretical struggle
but what what game today isn't so with
the white pieces is d4 from vidit we
have Knight to f6 c4 g6 Knight to the C
3 and B 5 the groom field defense is on
the board we've see captures Knight
captures and E 4 I'm going for the main
line Knight captures B captures and
Bishop to g7 and well Bishop to c4 is
the most played move here with Bishop to
e3 also a very popular line c5 attacking
the center making use of this beautiful
dragon on g7 Knight to f3 strengthening
d4 and Queen to a5 now pinning the c3
pawn again with ideas of capturing on d4
so Queen B - now the C pawn is no longer
pinned and the nice the c6 putting more
pressure on the d4 pawn and here a rook
the c1 was the go-to move up until this
year it would seem so now rook the b1 is
the move people are playing in 2020 with
a 6 and only now rook the c1 now why
this is so I'm sure it required a lot of
opening analysis and you know asking the
the engine for advice but it seems that
this is the way it sits played today and
ok
C capture son B for C captures this was
all played before and we have a Queen
trade characters captures and now b6
not allowing d5 we have Bishop to d3
continuing development and now castles
and now rook the c-4 is was the the idea
here you just play Brooks before you
bring the other
cover to see one double looks on the C
file now which is the only open file on
the board for the moment and it does
make sense but here instead we have h4
now perhaps with ideas of making some
weaknesses here opening up the the file
for the rook by pushing h5 so h6 and now
there is one game where if I was played
so you kind of numb down the the bishop
on g7 and also there is one game where
h5 was played but here rook the c5 and
it is now as of move 16 that we have a
completely new game so let's see how
Marcus deals with it we have rook to b8
developing the rook and also adds a
third attacker to the d4 pawn and now
well you could try and defend it maybe
go back rook to c4 but doesn't really
make sense since you already said that
you're not interested in rooks before
you want to play rook to c5 so rook the
b1 and here this is what we did
obviously prepared Marcus now has to
decide whether you grab the pawn or not
so let's see what happens if you rub the
pawn if Knight captures on d4 let's say
everything is straight at Knight
captures Bishop captures captures
captures and now you get King to e3 you
attack the rook you get out of the pin
rook back to a4 attacks a two and now
rook the c7 is very strong so black is
up a pawn but White has insane activity
it will be very hard for black to
develop for example if you capture rook
c1 just wins the game since you cannot
save the bishop you if you go here the
reub just captures it there's no
defending the pieces so what you would
have to do have to look the c7 is not
capture but play something like e 5 free
some squares for your or light square
Bishop to be developed but then you get
Bishop c4 now you go after the f7 pawn
and after let's say this captures
captures your gonna capture on b7 and
only only white can be better here or
it's just a plain draw for example rook
checks you move the King you capture
here and then let's say you just
continue checking up and down and if y
doesn't wanna part with these pawns you
we might have a draw by and by
repetition so this is basically what
lurks in the position after this rook to
be one idea and offering of the d4 pawn
so Marcus decides against it we
the shabak the f8 now forcing the rook
to move back
rook the c-4 now defending the d4 pawn
and Bishop to d7 just continuing
development offering the b7 pawn but not
really fruit characters n95 just picks
up one of the rooks so don't want to do
that so look the b6 a very active move
asking black how will you continue
development so the Shabak t8 now freeing
up the D file for the rook and now look
back the c1 now already there's the
threat of rook captures because you no
longer have this very nice fork and here
Bishop to g7 again adding a third
attacker to the d4 pawn and while you
could now maybe even go for recapture
some b7 and then again we trade
everything captures captures captures
captures center captures rook the c3
Bishop to b5 is the threat now going
after the bishop here but after rook c3
it's a it's a pretty equal ish game so
but it decides against it he pushes a 5
he says okay now you are no longer
attacking the d4 pawn this bishop is now
a much weaker than it was and your b7
point is still hanging and now rook a to
beat just defending the pawn seems to be
one of the ways for black to go
but Marcus against again goes for a more
active approach Bishop to f8
now he gives up the pawn for some very
active ideas or or so it seems
rook captures an b7 and now Knights the
B for attacking the bishop here also d8
you ponies under attack if you allow
captures then Bishop to b5 check will be
very strong black will have won the
bishop pair and maybe even tie down this
rook so it won't be able to escape but
we will see so first Bishop to c4 not
allowing captures or grabbing of the
pawn and a2 we have Bishop to c6 now
putting the bishop to this very nice
diagonal look back to c7 and now Bishop
to b5 we have the show back to b3 again
keeping an eye on your a to pawn and now
Knight to d5 now going after the bishop
on e3 and now Bishop captures on d5 it's
it's it's
strong overnight to be just left there
Bishop to e3 is coming and well this
rook just might run out of squares so we
have the shop characters on b5 rook
after son b5 and now rook the c8 asking
do you want to trade here and then I get
to the other look over to see 8 so of
course Roger doesn't we have looked to
d8 and now rook captures on a 8 we have
rook captures and now you might have
some problems for example if you go for
the seemingly active rook the c7 right
away black can just force a draw here
because the the two bishops will will
have no problems harassing the rope to
just rule there's a b4 check King c2 and
Bishop to a5 will make quick work of the
rook you don't want to go here because
then you allow the C file for for the
rook which will come with check so rook
the c5 if you want to keep the C file
but now there should be six and you can
just keep merrily harassing the rook
rook c5 Bishop b4 or b6 doesn't matter
basically I draw by repetition so after
this rook captures an a we have Bishop
to f4 here we did freeze the e3 square
for his king so let's see what happens
King to g7 also black improves the
position of the King keeps an eye on the
h6 pawn so the bishop now can be
developed now rook the c7 and now Bishop
to b4 check but now it's not a problem
since you can move came 2 e 3 and now
any Bishop to a5 harassing of the rook
will be met with the rook to c1 so
that's that's a big difference here so
rook to d8 instead and now g4 we have
rook the d7 now offering a roof trade
but rook the c8 since wife controls more
space of course he doesn't want to trade
down we have a 5 starting to push the
pawn and now push up the g3 slowly
making room for this point to be pushed
to f4
Bishop to e6 pushing the room back route
back the c2 and now brush up the b7 just
assuming this very nice diagonal
Knights the g1 freeing the DF 3 square
so you can push f4 we have g5 and now f4
we have G captures on f4 bishop
characters and butter back to e7 going
after the age for pawn and now
not brusha back to g3 but rather the
pawn to h5 so grabbing even more space
we have Bishop to e6 just waiting to see
what white will do white goes back
Knight to f3 and it seems that the best
idea for black is just to go back with
Bishop to b7 and keep keep playing this
game asking White's to come up with a
plan
but Marcus decided to go for another
active idea he played Bishop to b4
instead and now well a very important
Square was left behind but feel free to
pause the video and try to figure out
what you would play here how would you
continue this position while I give you
a couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on spotting the square that was left
behind and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's g5 the
bishop from east 7 no longer helps with
the defense
so of course g5 and now the knight can
come to g5 and from g5t 4n from E 4 to
d6 and it's basically just a a chain
reaction so H captures we have Knight
captures and now Bishop back to b7 which
is an excellent Square for the bishop
but now night Stewie for saying that I
don't care if you capture here if you
capture I'm just gonna capture and that
my position is just much better I
control the only well it's not the only
the G foul is also open but I'm the one
who controls the open C file I have a
fast H pawn I'm just gonna play h6 bring
the rook over here bring the roof to g7
it's gonna be it's gonna be a fairly
easy game for me so instead after Knight
to e4 Bishop back to e7 not allowing the
knight to come to f6 or d6 for that
matter but doesn't work Knight to d6
just the same now of course it's an
excellent square for the knight you you
are always pressuring the bishop if you
capture then it's well you just have to
past points look the c7 is coming
there's no no defending against this so
Bishop to d5 instead but now h6 with
check with King to g6 and here of course
you cannot play rook here because the
bishop covers that so rook the c1 now
making room for
rook to g1 to be played and it was in
fact in this position on move 46 that
mark
shraeger resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here for example
we could show let's say you try to
relieve some of the pressure for example
you will not capture right away we're
still gonna go route you one checking h7
rogue g-seven check the H bone is nicely
guarded King here and now capture and
you have a lot of well you you now have
two passports and it's hard for black to
find a move for example if Bishop c6 the
guarding the rook preparing f6 the trade
the rook you have this very nice
breakthrough of d5 freeing some squares
for the for the White King he captures
you're gonna go King the d4 and now ESU
will be able to trade rooks but now King
c5 saying that if you capture I'm gonna
capture with check and then pick up your
Bishop here so Bishop to a4 and now King
captures on d5 and while you can now
finally capture here it's it's
insufficient because King e6 and now the
the D pawn wins you black will have to
give up the bishop here and because you
still have the a 2 point it's of course
a winning position and if you don't go
for this trade instead after work to c1
you could try something else but there
there's not much better if he if 7
you're still gonna go rogue do you want
and go for this g7 square Bishop to f8
defends this but now nice to I ate and
there is no defense Knight f6 seems to
come with with a fork and there is no
way of avoiding everything for example
if you move the rook it's just not f6
check King h8 and the rope the g8 mate
so whatever you do here it's completely
lost and of course it is justified that
the Marcus resigned here and an
excellent victory for vidit in round 3
of the practice festival so let's check
out the standings after three rounds
here no those are understandings let me
just I have to load them ok yeah these
are the standings so let's just check it
out after after three rounds it's fitted
in first place with two and a half out
of three points followed by Nikita with
YouGov earlier a Sefolosha and young
chief still do that with two points with
one and a half it's nils grande listen
David on Tony Hara and with one point
Marcos Roger pantalla harikrishna same
chance and and we
only half a point which is well someone
always has to have have a bad start
David Navarro who who is the the
favorite as he's you know playing on
home turf but yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank shaman ass-fuck Andrew J Davis
Austin Laird Dennis start Nick and
Mohammed Reza Reza for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous video serum thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice practice festival continuing the
morphe saga and of course checking up on
your wonderful suggestions so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your weekend